what's the first thing that got
cancelled was it was after uh Frasier
heard you had to cancel before I think
I've never really done a series before
before I did Cheers
so after Frasier I didn't kind of think
the next the next show I did was back to
you and we went on the writers strike
and then after that they didn't want to
keep doing it it was that a hard squall
to get because you probably never gotten
that call before and it's the first time
they tell you really yeah it was okay it
is what it was okay you know it's like
okay I got it
that's why I had my heart attack then
too that was pretty interesting I just
had a heart attack I was working at Fox
we tried to get the show back into
production and that wasn't gonna happen
so I got a call from a Fox executive it
said and by the way we need you to move
out of your offices it was batting a
thousand I was writing and I was riding
in a cab in the back of a cab after
leaving the hospital in Hawaii Hawaii
yeah things were okay you know yeah my
life turned out fine yeah a year later I
was married to a different woman and I
have three kids with her now and you
know things are really fantastic thanks
for good right now yeah yeah heart
attack what are you doing
I was paddleboarding stand-up paddle and
I had done that thing you know where you
go down to about 20 30 feet underwater
and you lift up a stone and walk along
the bottom of the I know do the I might
said well it's it's it since a couple of
movies okay it actually is a real thing
and then I paddled back but you know
it's one of those things I stood up and
I felt a little funny and then I
realized and I'm having a heart attack
you know that you are having are do you
feel like in the moment oh my god what
if this is it you start going through
those feelings you just go let's take
care of this right now well I was I was
pretty calm about it the only problem
was there was a there was an hour and a
half wait for the ambulance because it's
Hawaii oh my god and that was a little
bit that was a little disconcerting I
kept thinking you know come on sir and
this guy be here by now but I was in
severe pain you are and uh that but I
just kept breathing deeply and you know
the actors you know it's breathe try to
go with it oh but I did say as I said a
little prayer
of you know don't show me anything no
funny lights no nothing
yeah yeah let's get this over what's
good let's get this resolved and I got
things I got to do
did you for you to just to get yourself
to like how far was the hospital like
you have to 40 minutes you're like I
said give me a bicycle there's somebody
sitting there holding my hand at that
point it'll it's my ex-wife screaming at
me and that's it okay
but you kind of knew what England you
felt some tingling is that what happened
I felt a dove dizzy
they're like a loss of consciousness
kind of yeah so it's just
and then the pain kicked in like okay
that's what this that's that that's that
Wow one more Jim and Sam catch up with
full episodes and interviews from
celebrity guests anytime on demand using
the Sirius XM app